Beyond this concrete structure lies
Sudan territory Aid officials say on a
daily basis they still register between
2300 new refugees who come into Eastern
Chad over the past seven or eight months
we've seen hundreds of thousands in fact
more than 600,000 Sudanese refugees
displaced by the ongoing fighting inside
Sudan who have crossed this way and that
added to more than 600,000 other sudanes
refugees displaced by early conflict in
Western dfor numbering at more than
600,000 uh people now United Nations and
other Aid agencies are saying that they
have only one month food supply left to
help 1.2 million people in this part of
Eastern CH in addition to uh cases of
malnutrition PE people who are actually
needing assistance in other parts of CH
now they say unless heal comes their way
there won't be any food left to serve
these people at the end of January now
what we're hearing also is that over the
past few months we've seen a reduction
in the cases of malut nutrition simply
because of the constant supply of food
items and there is this concern that
unless help comes their way this
Improvement will be eroded over the past
over the next few months simply because
families that were sustained with food
supplies and food Aid will no longer
receive that Aid now uh a lot of people
are concerned that uh over the next
three or 4 months when people will be
entering the lean periods cases of
malnutrition will rise again ahamed rris
Al jazer on the Sudan Chad
border make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer